ladies and gentlemen one of the most
played
in Hollywood mr. Steve Martin
thank you David Letterman's monologue I
thought was really funny tonight of
course anything would have seemed funny
following Arthur Hiller you know
whenever I'm doing one of these
big-budget high-profile Hollywood movies
someone always asked me what exactly is
film editing and I always reply how
should I know you're the director
but we're here tonight because we love
movies how many memories will we carry
with us all our lives because of them I
can still remember sitting in a darkened
theater with my arm around 17 year old
Mary Jo Rasmussen trying to get the
first base I can even remember the name
of the movie The Lion King
and here are the nominations for film
editing this year
Arthur Schmidt for Forrest Gump
Frederick Marx Steve James and bill
Hobbs II for hoop dreams Sally Mindy for
pulp fiction Richard Francis Bruce for
the Shawshank Redemption John Wright for
speed and the Oscar goes to
Arthur Schmidt for Forrest gone
well the taxi driver said it when he
said wow forest would have known what to
say he probably just would have said
okay and let it go at that but I have a
few more little things to say when
you're on the receiving end of the work
of so many gifted collaborators who get
to come up here and get something like
this and I have to thank them all for
making this and gump happen especially
Bob Zemeckis who stretches himself and
the medium of film every time he goes
out and makes a film and in so doing he
stretches all of us who have the
challenge and the fun and the excitement
and the pleasure of working with his
amazing talent thank you Bob and thank
you all very much
Sally Field open
after right after these words